first of all Ted is there any scope for
a technological or legal middle ground
well I think that Congress should
consider the alternatives our elected
representatives are put in that position
in order to do that to think about
solutions to these difficult problems
and that's what this debate was all
about the government does not have the
authority to require Apple to redesign
its iPhone to disable the
characteristics that it put into the
system which is what its customers
wanted there's no legal authority for
that now and one judge has already held
that so there has to be some discussion
about how to solve this problem if there
is but you cannot conscripted company
such as Apple to do something to change
its products there are we have civil
rights that prevent that sort of thing I
spoke with attorney general Loretta
Lynch yesterday who said the middle
ground is the courts let this be decided
on a case-by-case basis as it already is
in the judicial system under any
circumstance would that satisfy Apple
I'm amazed that she would say that it
wouldn't solve anybody's problem you
might have one court going one way and
another court going another way FBI
director Comey himself yesterday said
this is a problem he said it's one of
the most difficult problems or the most
difficult I've ever fest faced as FBI
director and before that he was Deputy
Attorney General this is something that
Congress needs to debate one way or the
other if you do on a case-by-case basis
you're going to have different outcomes
in different cases in different parts of
the country director Comey says they've
got 12 or 13 other cases in which
they're trying to do this in federal
courts the Manhattan district attorney
said he had two hundred and five iphones
he wanted in to you can imagine multiply
that by every jurisdiction in the
country a case-by-case solution is no
way to go about this at all and I'm
amazed that the Attorney General would
say that now Ted I've spoken to security
experts
to say that they believe there are
technical alternatives here that don't
involve building a master key to all of
our iphones and in four in fact former
ahead of the National Security Agency
general Keith Alexander told me he
doesn't buy apples argument that this is
the only technical way are there
technical alternatives well there might
be technical alternatives in fact
director call me yesterday when asked
about whether he had consulted with
other branches of government to try to
solve this problem so that the
government wouldn't be forcing Apple to
redesign its product and he said we've
talked to everybody who will talk to us
but what does that mean has he consulted
with the NSA is the NSA the National
Security Agency are able to help but not
willing to help I don't know the answer
to that question the experts at Apple
which designed this iphone say there is
not another way to do this except to
give the government what it wants except
to redesign the system to break down its
security system which is that what tens
of millions hundreds of millions of
people have relied on when they bought
the product to begin with there
depending upon the security that Apple
built into the iphone and the government
wants to destroy that if the government
has figured out a way to get around that
problem itself without causing Apple to
redesign the iphone well then they
should do something like that and the
government officials involved in this
should be asked that question directly
so tied back to my question is there a
middle ground because it sounds like
Apple saying there is it well there
isn't a middle ground that I know of
that requires Apple to go to work for
the government we have a constitution
the Constitution does not allow the
government that can script private
citizens to invent products or to change
the products that they have invented in
order for the government to look into
the product or to cause the product to
do what it wants that's a very very
significant thing there may be ways now
the government has considered issues
like this in a in a statute call
the community assistance to law
enforcement act Kalia and it
specifically exempted companies like
Apple from having to do this sort of
thing Congress might consider some of
these things but if you're asking
Bloomberg or fox or the wall street
journal or Apple to redesign their
programs to supply assistance to law
enforcement a manufacturer of a car or
anyone like that then the government
doesn't have the power to do this except
in the most exigent circumstances and
the government hasn't demonstrated that
those circumstances exist and when we
talk about this now we're talking about
a system that would break down the phone
not just in this case the government
said it's about one phone and now
director Comey admits that it's not
about one phone it's a precedent that
they would use in other cases so this is
a very very important point once you
cross over that line there's really no
limiting principle that the government
has articulated Ted one of your
arguments is that it would cost Apple
ten engineers four weeks to do this
Apple is the most valuable company in
the world it has thousands of engineers
if any company has the resources to do
this isn't it Apple Apple could do it it
could devote a segment of its
engineering program and other
technicians to do something like this
what's the limit how many people what
companies that what if the same thing
that is being asked of Apple could be
asked of a smaller company it's the
principle that the government doesn't
have the right and there's no legal
authority that gives it that right to
require a company such as Apple to
redesign its program it's not just
redesigning the programmers not just
putting engineers to work to create a
product that the government wants that
Apple didn't design and specifically
avoided designing it is asking Apple to
create something that it doesn't have to
do it that to create a new product and
all those apple iphones that are out
there with tens of millions of people
that the programs that they bought it
for the security so that they could keep
their most intimate private information
including things like the location of
their children or where their children
go to school that's kept private now the
government is asking Apple to undo that
so it's important that Apple would be
required to supply engineers and
resources to the government's desires
but it's more important that they will
have been required to damage a product
that millions of people with tens of
millions of people rely on Ted Donald
Trump is closer than ever to be in the
Republican nominee he has called for a
boycott of Apple products if they don't
do this he said he'll force Apple to
manufacture in the United States what do
you have to say to Donald Trump well I'm
not going to get in the middle of the
presidential campaign presidential
people running for office and Donald
Trump is no exception or would take
positions that attract attention to them
the American public and the public all
over the world that rely on the finest
products ever made to supply them
information to provide their ease in
conducting their lives to provide all
sorts of answers to their own problems
they are the ones that will decide that
Apple's product is living up to what is
promised to be and apples keeping the
trust and resisting intrusions on the
trust that it has for the people who
have emplaced that trust in Apple to
design a product that they depend upon
that's the important thing now Ted at
the Congressional here hearing lawmakers
pressed what does Apple actually want
Congress to do somewhat unsuccessfully
what is your legislative strategy what
do you want Congress to do what Congress
should do its job which is to consider
the various different alternatives the
impact on citizens balance the concerns
of law enforcement which we respect
apples cooperated in every possible way
with the government except for throwing
out the design
of the iphone and redesigning it
Congress needs to consider what
technological resources exist what can
be done by the government without
conscripted private citizens to change
the products that they make and things
like that there should be hearings there
should be expert testimony they may have
started yesterday there was testimony
not just from director Comey of the FBI
for whom I must say I have the most
enormous respect he's a tremendous
public citizen we're lucky to have him
but they have testimony from him have
testimony from the head of the NSA and
other security agencies testimony from
experts that worked in the private
sector and testimony from law
enforcement let's let's have this debate
director Comey has asked for this debate
the CEO of Apple Tim Cook has asked for
this debate let's have that debate I
can't predict where it's going to go but
we should have the discussion and we'll
see where it takes us now when I spoke
to attorney general Lynch she shot down
the argument that this violates the
first and fifth amendment saying and I
quote Apple is not a target in this
matter we are not alleging that they
have done anything wrong how do you
respond to that well Apple has First
Amendment rights whether it's been
accused of doing something wrong or not
you're absolutely right Apple has done
nothing wrong and director Comey said
Apple has been very very helpful in this
and every other investigation they've
gone as far as they possibly can but
Apple has a responsibility when it's
being asked to communicate with iPhones
all over the worlds that it's created
that's a First Amendment right so you
you have a First Amendment right I'm
surprised the Attorney General that she
would suggest that people only people
that are accused of doing wrongdoing
have First Amendment rights you have a
First Amendment right no one's accusing
you of having done anything wrong and me
to the apple has First Amendment rights
to protect its product to avoid the
government compulsion of what it should
have to say to its products in order to
change the design of those products um
and it
as the responsibility to protect the
integrity of the right of privacy of all
of the people that have the world who
have depended upon Apple to protect the
privacy that they used with respect to
these phones you can imagine what a
tyrannical government can do to
individual privacy of individuals who
are wishing to communicate with one
another or their neighbor or in in
private so we're talking about the
rights of Apple to make sure that its
iPhone has the integrity that it
carefully built into it so all of those
are constitutional rights everyone has
civil rights in this country not just
accused people are accused of crime now
Apple is also arguing that its
responsibility to its customers is
greater than any responsibility it has
to the government but there's another
argument to be made that Apple may not
even have an iphone if it did not
benefit from the government's own
investments in technology from
everything from GPS to the Internet what
if the government made it a condition
that to benefit from all of that
investment Apple would have to comply
with legitimate law enforcement requests
well I hate to get extreme about this
but it reminds me of the 13th amendment
the United States government that's
prevent made it illegal to have slaves
and that's over obviously an
overstatement I don't mean to mean that
literally but the government cannot
conscripted citizens the government
can't say in order for used for you to
use technological information that might
have been produced and put in the public
domain by the government you have to
agree to work for the government that
just does not work I don't know where
that could possibly come from by the way
Apple is is a is a force of great good
for this country apple has used its
creativity its technical ah gical where
with all its resources to develop
products that have changed our lives
that have made us more free where would
we be today without inventions like the
Apple iPhone and its various iteration
and the iPad and other devices that have
created and made us free and the reason
that why Apple has done that the reason
that Apple has been so successful doing
that is a constitution that gives
incentives to inventors to provide the
creativity that exists in Silicon Valley
that has made the economic energy and
engine of this country so successful
that's free enterprise but free
enterprise depends upon a rule of law
and consistency by the government and
the various civil rights that are given
to all citizens including companies that
are developing products that we all use
all right Ted Olson apples head lawyer
Gibson Dunn & Crutcher Ted thank you so
much for joining us